I wouldn't that flicks with rocket
because I feel like rocket would
probably be a lot more quiet during a
movie I think that star-lord just talks
like it I just he just doesn't shut up
[Music]
I need a roommate that's clean so I
would have to say an Avenger
don't hate me guys I'd rather be with
the guardians of the galaxy when I sleep
by snore and my snore is more of a
whistle so they understand that and they
put tape over mine them and my Guardians
ago I don't know any of you first of all
I would never ever wish to live in a
studio apartment and New York City if I
had to be stuck there trapped there like
a rat I'd want it to be with the
guardians because I love them dearly
they are my friends and family tights
and and you know I'd have a dance belt
it'd be okay
12 foot long cape I'll take anything
with tights I actually stopped doing a
movie one time because I was gonna have
to wear tights I would like a cape yeah
keep it's so much cooler yeah they're
really cool can you fly with a cape yes
[Laughter]
cape I'm hoping that I can wrap around I
like scarves to just kind of cool it up
tights are just just not good and just
you know all the little kids or just be
traumatized
I think I got more of a moral would be a
little nicer IIIi think my sister is
still very volatile I'd rather bring
Gamora
home to bring to meet my parents but I'd
rather take nebula out on a date the
more was much nicer never eyes just
sugar could kill everyone
yeah not the owner and not yeah like a
sulking and being socially awkward Moody
and then she like killed her pet w emma
has also told tools you know her arm can
come out and and and become like a
little hedge trimmer no yes that nebula
I didn't hang out with rocket we've
become pretty good pals in this month
Laura Netflix and chill yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna choose star-lord as well
because I think that we would want to
watch similar things man test a Kenny
when she's so sweet I'm not gonna have
to go with mantis mantis is like she
could touch me and know when I want to
stop and get a coffee and you know that
kind of stuff I would go with myself
does it make sense
I choose mantis Oh mantis she's sweet
she never talks back I know I just I'll
go with mantis
baby grew come on we'd be building my
coconut trees and pissing off all the
animals in the aisle
baby roots a better dancer oh yeah the
entertainment quality money the value I
mean the thorah talks way too much first
off baby Groot you understand exactly
what he's saying he wouldn't talk to you
if you don't want to be stuck somewhere
with baby Groot then you're just a
horrible horrible person baby group you
might be able to get off that Island
Thornton gonna do much with a hammer I
don't think if we're being practical
about it you have to choose Thor but
like just for like enjoyment and
cuteness I mean group maybe you can put
yourself in the tree ink and swim with
yeah like a boat yeah you can make a
raft
[Laughter]
[Music]
no it's S&M here I would be massaged
with Thor's hammer or with the [ __ ]
kind of guy I think the hammer thing is
good I guess if you're you know that's
like stuff he used to play when you were
a kid do you want a sex mat from it I go
with the tickling rather than the hammer
I'm gonna go with Thor's hammer and also
because that I'm sure that's quite a
good-looking man it's it's kind of
sexual right like my sorry but I don't
know your mind just feeling a little
unnerved by the tickled by with the
Wolverine things kids like and you're
just gonna get cut high gentle can he go
because yeah cuz if he can be really
gentle the nitrous that
you
[Music]